merci monsieur le président nous vous
remercions de permettre
exceptionnellement aux membres du cercle
des femmes parlementaires de partager un
message de solidarité dans le cadre de
cette mesure il ya 25 ans le 6 décembre
1989 la nuit et la neige tombés sur
montréal quand les premiers coups de feu
ont déchiré les murs de l'école
polytechnique à la veille des examens
dans les salles de cours et les corridas
brouillant de vie la mort s'est invitée
muni d'une carabine semi-automatique
une heure plus tard les imériens cloué à
nos écrans des brancards chargé des
parents affolés des policiers
déstabiliser des rumeurs sur le nombre
de tireurs des garçons ce choc
décrivant tueur qui ne faisait que les
femmes ce jour-là 14 femmes été tué 14
personnes blessé des dizaines de
familles d'amis et de collègues étaient
marqués à jamais quatre d'entre eux se
suicidèrent et on apprendrait plus tard
que le tueur avait dans sa mire
une quinzaine d'autres québécoises
connues et influente le québec une
société tranquille
prosper progressiste et fier d'être
reconnu comme l'une des plus égalitaire
de la planète basculer dans
l'incompréhension et la question que
tous se posent et pourquoi ici 25 ans
plus tard nous sommes là 33 femmes 33
parlementaires de différents partis aux
opinions diverses mais unis par des
valeurs d'égalité de justice et de
solidarité
individuellement nous avons fait des
choix parfois difficiles pour atteindre
cette assemblée
nous avons vécu no doubt trouver des
appuis accepté de payer le prix en
termes de conciliation famille travail
nous avons combattu le cynisme de
plusieurs envers la politique et
affirmer notre compétence
il leur suffit de l'histoire terrible
d'un animateur vedette pour que le
silence se fracasse pour que des femmes
connues jalouses de leur vie privée
révèle la honte et la corse subit lors
d'agressions passé pour que des milliers
de femmes anonymes les suit dénoncent à
leur tour leurs agresseurs et exprime
l'urgence d'agir car la violence à
l'égard des femmes et des enfants ne
semblent pas se résorber
elle nous rejoint dans nos maisons nos
rues nos lieux de travail ailleurs
elle suivit dans les camps de réfugiés
les bidonvilles les champs de bataille
les maisons cossues les ateliers sombre
les usines ou portes cadenassées
individuellement nous nous pensons à
l'abri nous sommes des femmes choyé qui
ont pris leur place dans l'espace public
qui ont les moyens d'agir de se défendre
et de défendre les leurs nous sommes des
battantes
nous sommes ses 1500 québécoise tués
depuis 1989 par des ex conjoints
incapable de supporter la séparation
incapable de demander de l'aide
nous sommes renel harper 16 violet est
laissée pour morte dans les eaux glacées
de la rivière assiniboine à winnipeg
elle a survécu mais depuis 1981 près de
1200 femmes autochtones ont été
assassinés ou ont disparu
au canada six chefs ya assassiné au nom
de l'honneur puis noyé au fond du canal
rideau à kingston même ici au canada ne
sommes pas des cas isolés
nous sommes 7 200 étudiantes enlevé dans
une école du nigeria par le groupe boko
haram est transformé en épouse esclaves
sexuelles et soldates on dira que nous
confondons tout que nous ingérons que
nous balises ont des horaires on les
compare aux sens et wiam des québécoises
nous persistons et disant qu'il ya un
lien entre ce soit d un fait divers
c'est devenu de justesse égale oublié il
faudra que les hommes s'y mettent aussi
vous tous collègues parlementaires amis
amoureux frères fils citoyens amour de
nos vies compagnon de no âge par les
respecter et aimer les femmes autour de
vous et élever vos enfants dans cet
esprit
nous sommes fiers de voir que
l'assemblée nationale fera sa part
puisque une commission parlementaire et
un forum public se penchera bientôt sur
la violence sexuelle à l'égard des
femmes et ce dans un climat non partisan
et en vue d'un plan d'action un jour au
québec comme ailleurs vous feront des
dizaines de milliers à commémorer la
tuerie de polytechnique
nous vous invitons ou que vous soyez à
participer à cet exercice de mémoire à
remplacer dans vos souvenirs
le nom du fort parfum des 14 jeunes
femmes au sourire éclatant et au regard
confiant pour ne jamais oublier annie
turcotte 20 ans qui avait choisi le
génie des matériaux pour améliorer
l'environnement
elle ne pourra jamais pu nager et
plonger comme elle l'aimé tant anne
marie edward 21 ans ses parents susan et
james se battront férocement avec heidi
rathjen et wendy que pierre pour le
contrôle des armes à feu
maryse leclerc 23 ans c'est son père le
lieutenant pierre leclerc de la police
de montréal qui trouvera son corps
transpercé au couteau de chasse par le
tueur
juste avant qu'il ne se suicide
geneviève bergeron 21 ans elle voulait
s'imposer en génie civil
elle chantait et jouait de la clarinette
sa mère thérèse dev-yhu femme politique
montréalaise s'engagera dans la
fondation des victimes du 6 décembre
barbara daigneault 22 ans tout comme son
père professeur à l'école de technologie
supérieure elle avait choisi le génie
mécanique en 1991 employés étudiants de
le ts créeront le fond barbara
daigneault qui par des bourses
encouragera des femmes à devenir
ingénieur
maryse laganière 25 et d'être une
employée de pauli est une jeune mariée
qui ne verra jamais grandir les enfants
qu'elle aurait décidé en avril mai 22
ans elle ne sera pas ingénieur il n'y
aura jamais de problème à concilier
famille et travail
maud haviernick 29 ans dans 20 ans à
faire celui échanges rationnement à la
télé avec la mort du tueur
une femme blessée à une autre hélène
kolgen 23 ans elle avait déjà trois
offres d'emploi elle allait peut-être
choisir prendre nathalie croteau 23 ans
avec son amie hélène elle aussi en
dernière année de génie mécanique
elle avait prévu passer ses vacances
dans le sud michèle richard 21 ans elle
ne sera jamais les seigneurs en chef de
la reconstruction du pont champlain à
nice et arnaud 23 ans elle se voyait
partir en afrique et travailler à
coopération internationale avec son
frère serge qui lui aurait fait
découvrir son monde
barbara cloud chimiques vidovic 31 ans
elle avait immigré de pologne avec son
mari en 1987 lé mémorial
elle l'a fait découvrir à son frère pas
vaine sonia pelti 28 ans elle était à la
tête de sa classe et faisait la fierté
de son village de saint-ulric elle
recevra un diplôme posthume
leurs vies se sont arrêtées trop vite
c'est à nous tous et toutes
maintenant d'en garder la mémoire
vivante de transformer la noirceur en
lumière la haine en harmonie notre vie
continue faisons la meilleure ensemble
est ce que cette nation est adapté je
vous invite maintenant vous lever pour
une minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes de la tragédie de la police
technique